hello believe nation how you guys doing
happy Friday it's great to be here with
you I've got a question and an exciting
announcement as well so one of the
things that has come up consistently
with some of you guys in the comments is
I wish it was a place for us to share
our ideas to meet other people to be a
part of believe nation beyond just
YouTube maybe we should set up a
Facebook group maybe we should set up a
forum what do you guys want to do how
can we connect beyond just the YouTube
videos and my question you guys is that
something that is interesting for you
and the announcement is somebody has
already done it for us one of our super
subscribers Marvel decided on his own
initiative to go out and buy believe
dash nation com and he set up some
forums for us to be a part of and I've
been there and I posted a couple times
and another of other members are
involved millville it was his vision his
creation put it together he got J reyez
involved whose work with me on a number
of projects and they surprised me with
this I didn't know this was happening
the secret ninja project and they said
boom here you go Evan what do you think
and I love the idea and if it's
something that you guys find valuable
that idea of being able to connect with
other members of believe nation ask each
other some business questions help each
other out whatever it is you feel the
need for that form and willingness to
connect go check it out believe dash
nation com I'm gonna be in there as well
and I'd love to get your feedback I'm
sure may have bill I would also love
your feedback either in the forums or on
the comments here below so let us know
what you think thank you guys for
watching hope you close out the week
strong I believe in you I want you to
continue to believe in yourselves and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon